taken many CEOs have taken this action
they want their employees to know that
if they have heritage in other countries
or you know if they want to travel to
other countries or have several
passports that they're still welcome to
work there yes it's true
the notable thing about Lloyd
Blankfein's voicemail was sort of how
directly he said that he and the firm
Goldman Sachs didn't support the policy
as I was reading the news over the
weekend and and saw the memos that CEOs
sent out it was pretty notable that many
of them said we're in favor of
immigration were in favor of you know
the contributions that immigrants have
given to our corporation but they didn't
really take on the Trump administration
directly or or comment on the policy
directly and you know Lloyd's voicemail
he'd said this very clearly this is a
policy we do not support and so that
that was pretty interesting help us
understand the cultural import of this
within the financial sector over the
weekend there was a stream of memoranda
from Silicon Valley executives first of
all banking seemed to get in on this
late in the game with Goldman and
specific why is this so important it's a
good question and you know I'm not privy
to Lloyd's what he was thinking when he
did this but you know one thing with the
tech CEOs they have many employees who
are affected I think in Google's case a
couple of them were actually caught in
the airports so they were sort of driven
to respond a little quicker then then
Wall Street was but in the last few
years Wall Street has been competing
very closely with technology and and
other sectors but really with Silicon
Valley over Talent over over Talent and
for people and so one aspect of this is
sort of positioning yourself as hey this
is not something we're going to stand
for they can want other bank executives
financial services executives are
talking about this and as it relates to
Briggs it to because it feels like
suddenly there's no home for
or financial services anymore it's true
JP Morgan's operating committee put a
memo out over the weekend and they said
essentially that while they're in
support of you know defending the
country and safety they thought
immigration and diversity was really
important so obviously JP Jamie Dimon is
one of the people that sits on that
operating committee
he's been outspoken in favor of
immigration in the past Wells Fargo and
Morgan Stanley had memos out that
essentially said we're looking at how
this affects our employees they didn't
take on the policy directly Citigroup
and Bank of America so far have declined
to comment entirely staged horsemen as
well head Steve Schwarzman as well so
it's it's this continuum of people who
feel comfortable for whatever reason to
sort of take on the policy all the way
to CEOs and management teams who think
that you know their duty or it's safest
to just sort of stay out of it you've
read these it's the it's the audience
for these men was really the employees
themselves where these geared toward the
public into your care toward customers
as well good question I think probably
both but I think with most corporate
memos these days they're geared towards
the public and public consumption so but
I do think that if if it didn't affect
employees these CEOs wouldn't feel the
need to sort of you know take on the
administration right Trump has been you
know very he has shown that he's willing
to take on companies that don't that he
doesn't agree with or that don't agree
with him so I don't think the decision
is made lightly to sort of go out
against the policy of his you know I
think the the calculus has to include
employees many in support of the policy
Heather